the afternoon session so next here is
Mika it's going to apply for top down
lower paths for depth or circuits okay
thank you
um okay so this is a joint work with um
my students Arthur and Anastasia
um also Dimitri soccer club all of them
used to be at St Petersburg but now now
they're with me at dpfl for obvious
reasons
okay so it's a we have this new result
in Boolean circuit complexity so maybe
the model is
is partly familiar from the morning so I
draw circuits with all the Boolean
variables at the bottom it's kind of
important because I'm going to talk
about top down and bottom up
um and okay so we have the usual and or
a not gate and then my circuit produces
one bit of output at the top
um okay so I know some of you came here
for a Cutting Edge high-end research
stock but we're actually just going to
solve some exercises from our undergrad
class so this is an actual uh exercise
sheet from this spring
um
so one of the questions I put up is
um you know circuit complexity of the
parity functions if you have
um this Excel function you put it in
bits of input and you're supposed to
Output yes or one if the Hamming weight
is odd
I'm asking how to you know how can you
compute this simple function efficiently
even with just um
a linear size circuit
um so you know linearly many gates so
here's how you do it this is an easy
problem so you can start with n equals
two so I denote the xor function with
this blobs I have two input bits one
output bit how do you implement this
with the usual Boolean Gates well here's
one implementation it's actually a dnf
formula for it but the point is n is a
constant it's a constant size circuit so
how do you do it in general
um well here's how you can build this
binary tree of these um
parity Gates of fan in two and now you
just plug in that constant size circuit
for each of these blobs so that gives
you
a linear size circuit and in fact the
depth is pretty good too so
um uh or the login in fact that sort of
optimal like if I only give you and the
nor gates with
fan in two then any function that
depends on all of its variables needs
login depth
so maybe it's a bit more interesting if
I live the and an or gates to have
unbounded Fanning so uh like one does in
a DNA formula so this is uh another
exercise from the sheets but this is
already harder if
we are to judge by
what my students write on Piazza this
was the hardest problem even with hints
so I must
um
I'm asking to show that if you want to
compute this parity function with just a
DNA formula so you know or of terms each
term is a conjunction of literals then
you need loads of them so exponentially
many terms by the way
so I view a dnf as a depth to a circuit
always put the kind of negations next to
the inputs
so I don't know any takers how would you
solve this uh super difficult exercise
ideas
okay so so you're claiming that each
term needs to involve all of the
variables and why is that
otherwise you'll get like two
corresponding assignments if you flip a
bit it should change the value of the X
right
so I have here an example with n
variables so if I have a closer with uh
n it is only one satisfying assignment
but if one of these variables was not in
there I would create another satisfying
side before I could flick the bit you
didn't mention so that would make the
term access both an order and even
string and that's a contradiction so
um you would then cross the whole dnf
formula to accept something that has the
wrong parity
okay so that okay so
um
why the statement is silly question why
does the theorem follow from this maybe
the same test
um I mean you need
actually n minus one one value business
yeah so okay each term can only accept
one input and you have well this many
inputs that evaluate to one then I just
have to have one term for each of them
okay
so yeah we sold this without any hints
very good
um so maybe just to belabor the point
like what did we do here we said
the uniform is it's an or a bunch of
terms
and the way it's Computing my Boolean
function is a Boolean function bunch of
yes inputs a bunch of no inputs and the
or is a kind of uh I knew there's a kind
of a union so the the or kind of
constructs the set of one inputs as the
union of
inputs accepted at the low level so you
know set up one inputs Union of you know
things that the terms except
and just to really recap we could say we
gave a top-down uh lower bound argument
could say
so I'm going to repeat the proof
um look at the top funding is this
Fannin M if it's less than the number of
file inputs then there must be some term
that accepts two
inputs by this Union
but if you accept two inputs then you
actually
you must have left one variable out in
the term and so I this way I've found a
term that kind of accepts both
yes inputs and no inputs and that's a
that's a contradiction
foreign
circuit lower bound
you know any questions about this we
just uh so that if the depth is really
really low then you can't really save
anything you just have to
Brute Force parity
so I guess now one could ask like okay
what happens we know login debt you get
a linear size circuit
um depth two you get you know just an
exponential size what happens in between
so if we go higher
from
from depth to
so what's uh okay let's do step three
and what's the depth three circuit what
does it look like
well again I I just um
I put all the negations at the bottom uh
for each step we're gonna have a kind of
two types of circuits depending on what
the top gate is but
um whatever the topic it is the the ends
and ores alternate
um okay so I claim that actually already
for debt three you get an improvement
you can compute parity with
in this size which is uh well it's the
exponential but in root n
so how does how do you do that so here's
one way uh you can visualize it is I
have my end beeps and I
um bucket those end bits into root and
buckets each of size routine
so this is one bucket and I first
compute the parity of each bucket and
then I compute the parity of the
of the of the buckets
um so okay this is not an Android Note
circuit yet but you could plug in for
these parities there are implementations
as DNS so
if I do that so I just maybe replace
this in this diagram
let's see if I replace this guy with its
dnf implementation
um so you know how large a dnf do I need
well it's at most exponential in the
number of its inputs and it has only n
inputs so you get this
bound
by just replacing the top object
um so you could do that for actually
each of these
uh just plug in a dnf so that would give
you a circuit now so dnf of a d Avenue
so that's I guess steps four
um
how do you get depth three you need one
optimization in my strategy
yeah one layer of CNS yeah okay so you
do maybe the top with a CNF so just to
spell it out if you have uh
CNF dnfs you get
very annoying and or or and so so you
only get like three alternations of one
device you've had two layers of
Gates of the same type you can always
collapse them too
uh the same like like a single layer
okay so you know this pattern you can do
it um
kind of annoying way
drawings you can do this for any depth
and you get something like exponential
in well this quantity
okay so um the one punch line is that
this is tight so
um we now or we have known for a long
time that this is for any constant D
this is exactly uh the complexity of
parity
so the way to classically prove it and
there are a bunch of different methods
so maybe the most
most famous one is this uh switching
Lemma or random restriction method
um
there's also uh this raspers malinsky
polynomial approximation method that
will prove uh lower bounds all the way
to yeah constant depth
circuits I just want to maybe highlight
that these random restriction methods if
you know them the very bottom up so what
they do
is they say
even if you have a very tall circuit
they just look at the bottom most couple
of layers maybe they pick out a CNF
um from the bottom layer and they say yo
if you restrict the variables
accordingly the the whole function
simplifies of the the
CNF you picked simplifies with high
probability
actually it switches to your dnf so with
a single random restriction you can kind
of crunch the depth of the circuit down
by one
if you continue invoking this sort of a
Lemma you eventually kind of simplify
the whole circuit so this is how you can
like prove lower about and identify
you know limitations of constant depth
circuits but but it's a very bottom-up
strategy so
um what um
so you know it's super powerful uh
people like use it uh every day
um
to prove lower bounds not just in
circuit complexity but uh proof of
complexity and all over
um but okay so I personally also like an
alternative method to produce lower
bounds which is called a top-down method
so you know some kind of an argument
that analyzes this circuits starting
from the top gate
um so okay so these methods have been
used a lot as well
um
just a bunch of pointers we can
um I've got that message to prove lower
bounds for formulas I mean we don't have
super polynomial or a bunch of formulas
but some
quadratic formula um size four months
they can be phrased as stop-down
arguments
is a very
um very popular proving Laura bunch of
monotone circuits okay so without not
Gates in fact the earliest work there is
this um Carter and victorson they kind
of
um well they introduced what's all about
cards for victim games it's a connection
by which you can view circuits in the
language of communication protocols and
somehow naturally that language is very
very much a top-down language
um so many of these works that prove
monotone circular bonds they also have
like they're often faced in the language
of
um communication complexity
okay so then there's a third type of uh
lower bound result the top down method
has been used for and that's well for
depth three circuits so you know we can
do not just DNS but one more level
um
so yeah loads of papers have used this
but for some reason
they were always stuck at depth three so
we didn't know of how to use the stop
down method to lower brush with debt
four and that will be our main result I
mean spoiler alert it's in the title but
um
foreign
motivation
um
and also I don't know I mean there's
many
applications so you know that three
appears when you study the low levels of
the polynomial party in a classical
complexity Theory that's where I've
played around with these things the most
and historically that's how these
methods were introduced actually
um
okay so I've highlighted here a
particular weapons of hot star the
nuclear and good luck so so they have a
paper where they really kind of
establish this top-down method as a
style of lower bound to study for its
own sake so they
a reprove
uh some Target lower bonds using this
method and and they explicitly pose uh
the challenge of you know trying to make
this method work for depth four so
that's the earliest uh
mention of no I'm still stuck at debt
three
um but I also want to kind of maybe
correct some kind of a misconception
like sometimes hear let's say in
conference reviews that this paper is
like invented the top down method I
wouldn't quite uh put it that way so
I've I found like earlier papers that do
top down without like being too explicit
about it
so the earliest I found this is a Baker
and sellman let me just show you what
that
sure
yes so I mean that's actually one of the
questions I have at the end so there are
some
yeah some early results
it would take some time to say what the
function is right or one is proof but uh
yeah that's it
blocks here so they do that three times
because they want to know because the
bottom one doesn't work okay so I could
say but it is a very information with my
students too where we wanna pin down
maybe the constant in the exponent and
so then you need very precise arguments
and that's uh where these uh methods
there's also this um satisfiability
encoding level that gives like really
really tight bounce for which I did
three attitude
motivated as well
but okay so let me let me just flash
this Earnest paper I found that does
drop down so well they're motivated by
separating the second level of the
polynomial relative oracles whatever
that means it's you know
um
classical complexity Theory and they
actually include this nice quote uh it's
from Hartley Rogers I think this is the
textbook on compatibility Theory
important memories as an undergrad
reading this so he says or views uh much
of mathematics is a
that's a crutch for us to understand the
alternation of quantifiers so human mind
seems Limited in its ability to
understand and visualize Beyond four or
five alternations of quantifier
and I mean I sort of agree like when you
work on these things it's um
it's like painfully obvious how you can
even though everything is Elementary
it's so easy to get messed up so I want
to kind of put this up as a reminder for
myself to go slow today and um yeah
hopefully you will interrupt me when I'm
being too fast
um okay so um so the result we now have
is is a
debt for method
um and as you know we demonstrated to
reprove this um old lower Bound for
parity so we get quantitatively
basically the the right answer
um so you know it's just
a new proof of an old result
and and even more
it's even weirder than that in that this
is the method I'm going to discuss is
complete in the sense that
you know in a very there's a formal
sense in which it can prove any lower
Bond that's true
so you know this is a true lower bound
and this is this sort of a
non-constructive reason why there's
always a top-down proof of it so what
we've only sort of done is you know make
that proof explicit or constructive
but you know I'll discuss this
a bit later what it means to be complete
so this is not true of let's say the
random restriction methods or polynomial
approximation method they're very
powerful but there are some
um it's not clear that they can prove
any lower Bond that's true
so yeah um are we just like why are we
doing this if it's just like playing
around with
um like known uh questions I guess like
I have some long-term goals I mean we
didn't do anything new but I'm hoping
we're really starved for new techniques
in circuit complexity so I'm hoping that
you know doing something like this you
could um you know in the long term
settle some ambitious problems so for
example
um we don't understand alternation in
communication complexity so the best we
can do sort of is to prove lower bounds
for non-deterministic communication
protocols but not for
so that's like exist blah but not for
for all exists blah so that's already a
communication model for which uh we
don't know how to prove lower bonds and
the random restriction method sort of
completely failed there
um
an even easier goal is to show
um lower bounds for concept circuits
that have a layer of parities next to
inputs okay you can prove some lower
bounds using the polynomial
approximation method but what if I ask
you to show a particular function like
the inner product
cannot be computed there the problem is
both these circuit and this function is
both approximable below degree
polynomials so you need some more
specific
technique and you know
throwing lower bonds like this uh
they're sort of necessary
to show lower bonds for the
communication polynomic which in turn is
necessary for valence rigidity program
um okay so this is you know I don't have
any
um
this is just the kind of uh like the
research Grant proposal style of vision
but you know at least we're taking some
steps the last question for the next
three
so if I have a DNS of Charities we can
prove but not with one level more
and when you think that's important
is anything else
[Music]
um
so can we yeah does our method uh yeah
four against one of the really annoying
things about this you'd think that if
you find the right proof for depth four
then mathematical induction keeps you
need to get it for all questions bets
yeah but I don't know maybe we have the
wrong proof still uh so
one thing the other thing oh okay it is
no yeah so we just don't know how to do
it with top down Okay
um
yeah
this is the true principle functions of
each other restrictions model
s well maybe I sort of vaguely claim
that there are I mean to ask previously
there are some functions where we don't
know how to prove them with a render
restriction method by the top down but
they're like tips
three results already it's
uh
okay
prove this but of course like our F4
Builds on step three so I want to
revisit uh how people have used top-down
methods to prove the response for step
three so there are a couple of um
based briefly things my favorite and
what we build on is uh a technique that
uses something called bit on
predictability so
um so I guess now is the time to kind of
wake up you know uh
internalized is one key idea then you
can go back to email and Tick Tock but
this is a take-home message
um
so you know I just read somewhere that
every good talk should have one key idea
our proof has two ideas but I've just
chosen to you know Place one of them as
the key idea and so this is actually
from an earlier paper already
um by uh Myron victorson so
um so their main result is some kind of
an information theoretic Lemma
um so don't say anything about circuits
but actually
um and we'll go over this it's a
mouthful but this is easy to apply to
get the you know the tight lower Bound
for parity for deck 3 circuits
and yeah what again what I really like
about this is that
uh you don't need any background it's
just you know pure combinatorics
information Theory and um
you know just sort of applicable for for
circuit lower bounds
okay so let's see what what this is
trying to say so
it says that if I have a large set of
bit strings
so I I measured the size of a set
through its entropy so think of this
maybe uniform Distribution on the set so
you identify x with a random variable
uniformly distributed over it
so if this is a large set so that the
entropy is very close to N but okay
maybe you have entropy loss you know
something small you know the best number
you can put here is actually root n
um but yeah think of this as enter the
Epsilon
so then if I pick
um a random element from my set and a
random coordinate then this coordinate
will be unpredictable
to um
kind of it's hard to predict this
coordinate from just looking at a few
other coordinates of the bit string
so if you sample this is random then
with high probability
the if bit of the random variable it
remains
unpredictable so it still has entropy so
it can achieve both values zero and one
even if I condition some small subset of
other coordinates I you know for any
subset
of you know small enough size
a subset that doesn't look at the ith
coordinate
now if I condition
my random variable you know according to
you know this sample
so I'm looking at this small window well
it still does not kind of predict the
ith coordinates both values are possible
the best option
why is routine the best ability to put
it okay so
um yeah I claim that
um this this tight so I can give you an
example uh where this starts failing if
these numbers are
well like order a routine actually a
weird way to see this is optimal is that
I'm going to apply this memo to prove
the circuit for about and just take it
normal soft too because it's exponential
in this number okay but let me
I mean these numbers yeah so even when
you get that one yeah parameterize them
and say that the product of these should
be sub linear
so here's an example that shows this
says to move
and yeah it's a good reason to kind of
smile over what this is saying so I
arrange my end bits in this written by
Ruth Allen Matrix and then I say that in
each row
um the parent I fix the parity of each
row so maybe I fix all of the parities
to zeros
okay so you know my set X is just this
Subspace that has these parity
restrictions so how large is it well I
have all the strings except I've imposed
root and parities
okay so this is like entropy exactly uh
n minus root 10.
and now I claim that you know I can't
predict anything not with I probably
just for no X for no I can I
do I have unpredictable so I can't
predict so you give me any
very any position of a variable let's
pick this one
and I claim I can predict uh the value
here by reading well if I'm allowed to
read root n variables I can predict it
so
and what do I read so I can't read this
bit
but I want to read some other
s yeah so I guess I I just consider my I
will be all the other things
in its row so I know these values I
automatically know what this should be
um
yeah so you know you can even say
there's like almost unbiased for us we
just want it suffices that we get full
support for the variable
yeah let me explore this
a little bit further I
so the proof of this is this long I
don't know at the end maybe I can prove
it it requires one counter-intuitive
idea but it's otherwise quite short
let's see if we get there for now
uh maybe I want to try it you know let's
just play around with this Lemma a
little bit more
so just through the refresh now what
does dilemma say okay so here I have
um my Set uh of bit string so each row
is a bit string and I applied the Lemma
to this set so that means if I pick a
random element from the setting not pick
the final one and a random coordinate
maybe a bit like this blue
going
okay so these are typical choices
dilemma says
that bit is unpredictable
so
okay what does it mean it means I can
this is one way to apply dilemma is okay
maybe I take my
chosen bit string and I flip the one bit
that was unpredictable
um I claim that what I get
by doing this is something called the
local limit of this Set uh set of
strings X
so a local limit in this says that if
you look at
my string here
in any kind of local place
you're going to find some string in this
set X that agrees with it so okay if I
look at
well if I look at things outside the one
bit I flip then obviously the green guy
will agree with it so that's not very
interesting so let me look at another
local view that involves the bit I
flipped and maybe some other
variables
well because the green guy was
unpredictable it means that the pattern
one one here
um
it was such that
just conditioning on one one does not
predict the blue bit so what it means is
that there's some other string in the
set I mean I guess it happens here it
has the one one pattern and the blue
coordinate is you know has the opposite
value so you know both guys are possible
so again
no matter which
view coordinates of this Vector I
consider I can find some Vector in X the
degrees with it has the same local
pattern
so why is this useful for circuit
complexity well it's because
this fools low with cnfs
Okay so
if I start with this you know bag of n
bit strings that are all accepted by
some you know low with CNF so one low we
see in it it accepts all of these
strings
well I claim it also then must accept
this uh
local limit that I created
okay so you know why is that what so
what does a CNF do so CNF says I accept
my input
if this you know there's a bunch of
local checks that need to pass info in
order for me to accept my input so each
logo check it was at most this many
variables
and I claim that well the local limit is
accepted because whatever local check
you perform here you know whatever few
bits you uh consider
a check must pass there
because that local view is found
somewhere in this set and here the
checks always pass
I wonder if that was clear
so do we buy this claim that
um these sort of local limits if I I've
seen accepting all of this I kind of get
more strings that are accepted
I have another just to illustrate this
concept a little bit more so this is
just a like a formal definition of what
I mean by a local limit is that's what I
said because of the intuitively
um so I say that this
a string is a local limit if whenever
you look at it locally so you know you
pick some K bits that you're looking at
the string and that pattern is found
inside the set X so there's some little
x in x that also has the same passion so
that's just
um
the formal definition
okay
so
for arbit reset X I can
sort of close it under these uh local
limits you know we just argued that you
know if a CNF accept X it accepts all
its local limits that's all we need for
these lower bound proofs but
let me just say that these limits are
a very natural notion they sort of
exactly capture
the power of CNS so
um
maybe this is an aside comment towards
the completeness of the method so if you
want a full CNF if you want to say
um my CNS actually this pack of things
and when I said I want to argue it
accepts some other string
it needs to be a local limit
so if you collect all the local limits
for a particular set you're actually
getting the small list set that uh you
know include your original set and
moreover is you know said exited by some
um well kcnf
right
so a particular one
um
okay maybe I should not maybe belabor
these slides too much for us it's just
the only thing I want to take away is
that what does the unpredictability let
me say it says starting from the set X
if I pick a typical point in there and I
flip a typical bit I get a local limit
that's what the Dilemma says it you know
maybe I don't get all the local limits
but at least some of them
Okay so I wanna show how this lemon then
is applied to uh get the depth 3 circuit
lower bound
so let's try to do that it's actually
quite simple
um
okay so top down I start analyzing my
circuit from the top gate so I assume I
have too good to be true circuit
Computing parity so I know at the top
gate
the circuit okay correctly computes
parity so it accepts all of the yes
inputs that's in green it rejects all of
the zero inputs in red
okay now I need to take a step down the
circuit and try to find you know some
kind of a contradiction lower down the
circuit
and I'm just going to do a very naive
step
I'm going to pick one of these
sub-circuits or in this case C and Fs
but except the largest fraction of yes
inputs
so if you remember you know the or is
like a union the set of one input is
constructed it's a union of what is
accepted lower and I'm just going to
jump to the CNF that accepts the largest
possible fraction of yes inputs
so okay a little bit more quantitatively
if my circuit was of size or exponential
in and to the Epsilon
in this argument is going to work for
Epsilon up to root n but
just for intuition
so then it means that um I can find some
sub circuit that accepts this you know
one over this fraction of the set of yes
inputs
so that just translates into saying that
you know I can find a CNF that accepts
this set X
both entropy is very very large
yeah so this is exactly something I can
plug into the unpredictability Lemma I
remember found
a CNF accepting
many bit strings
any more of that
so I'm making a one simplifying
assumption
uh assuming that the the width of the
CNF here is slow you know it is
typically something like into the
Epsilon like log of the circuit size
um I mean I guess in an arbitrary
circuit it doesn't have to be this small
but but if you have
um
Clauses with much larger width
they sort of contribute very little uh
they can be ignored they they contribute
very little to the picture so
it's like the interesting case is when
the width also of the cnfs is roughly
the log of the circuit size
so allow me to assume that
okay so now we just apply
we just do
yeah we just applied the
unpredictability Lemma this is a large
set so it is if I pick a typical Point
Flip a bit okay so if I flip a single
bit I change the parity
so then I get a local limit that's
well perhaps the wrong parity
it's a local limit so the CNF still
accepts this limit so now I've found
that this CNF makes a mistake right
accepted all of these but actually it
also accepts something from the wrong
side of the function
questions about this step three that's
it it's you optimize this you can even
get this route n bound here but um
it's more or less clear
should we also get that fresh case open
so yeah
average casual robust is somehow
they're going
from depth 3 to depth four the average
cash flow run is somewhere in between I
would say
um
so
yeah to get average cash lower bound I
think you need the new methods that we
have I'm
that's my vague recollection
uh more questions
what was the error in the uh
[Music]
exponentially small in the uh it's so
what is the probability that you're
success with one over or the
so this is the actual statement
K times T is of linear oops
quantitative tightness
uh yeah we pretty much we didn't use
much of the parity except this uh so
yeah if I even had a function with you
know very high average Sensitivity I
guess this would still go through
yeah it's important we understand this
step three well because I could do
switch to depth four one more question
before I go forward
um
yeah so maybe it's like a different
document
um
complete why can't I do that bigger than
before maybe I'll address it you can
right like if it's completed so to be
able to prove it yeah but yeah maybe I
just passed that at the end so
um so so far I mean it seems pretty
straightforward let's see like what the
complications are for depth um four I
mean again
um there must be some because it wasn't
that easy although in hindsight I think
we just you'll see we're just about uh
have the tools to do this with um our
papers quite short of 10 pages
um
okay so let's do depth for
um and again top Downs I start at the
top gate so now it's an and gate
um okay so you know at the top I compute
all the yes inputs correctly all the no
inputs are rejected
and I again do a step down the circuit
so what kind of a step previously we did
this greedy naive step where we just
took the sub circuit that accepted the
most
yes inputs okay we have an and gate so
now we want a sub circuit that rejects a
large fraction of nodes and in fact in
our proof we we still follow the naive
uh strategy where you know we just pick
the sub circuit rejecting the most
uh strings
so that's what it looks like we didn't
do anything clever yet
um but let's see you know what happens
for the next step
uh which sub-circuit should I pick let's
see what happens if I do another naive
greedy step so it's an or gate so the
instead of getting constructed that's
the union of what is accepted here let
me choose
a subsidy that accepts a large the
largest fraction of yes inputs
another naive step
okay so far so good now we just know we
have a CNF it accepts all the green
things it rejects all the red things
otherwise I don't have any guarantees
so now you know let's Supply this
unpredictability thing again I mean I
have a good
sizable fraction of accepted strings
here
so you know let's apply the
unpredictability Lemma problem
I to reach a contradiction I really need
to say that you know you can't
simultaneously accept these and reject
these
so I would like to say the green guys
allow me to construct a local limit
that's in the red set
but so far I haven't been careful enough
uh it could be that this situation
happens I I've
gone down the circuit so much that the
the limits of the green set you know
they're just disjoint from the red I
didn't reach any contradiction
so I mean let me ask you how would you
fix this like maybe rewind one step
so go up one level
where should you step down to start try
to avoid this issue
is
yes so yeah is saying that
I wanna choose a subset that somehow
um
aware of this set
um and
that's this is yeah this is the first
modification is we need to Define
um a sort of a mirror image of the red
set so some kind of a set of yes inputs
that sort of locally or you know somehow
computationally indistinguishable from
the red
so we just call it the mirror set like
somehow it's like the analog is set but
just the answer is reversed
what would you propose as the mirror set
um
so here I just have an arbitrary set of
a large enough density
you know which sort of inputs on the
other side of the function should I
consider I mean I'm taking suggestions
for what
could be this mirror set
just to take things which are one bit
flip from something okay so that's a
good
suggestion I was hoping for that
okay so we have this red segment
a common intuition is you should think
of this sets all I know about them is
that they have you know good density so
they might actually be a error
correcting quotes So maybe the red set
looks like this in this Boolean space
and the proposition okay what kind of a
set would be difficult to distinguish
from this is well for each red set Maybe
I consider flipping
each of its coordinates so you know I
flip the first coordinate
I get some green right here second
coordinate so maybe the set the green
set will look something like this
yes so this is like the attempt you
first try and I think or Myron victorson
also tried this um that they was
motivated to try to find this depth for
proof
but somehow the reason this is difficult
is I mean why do why are you proposing
this it's because you'd like to
construct this local limits starting
from a green point you know jumping as a
local limit back to the red
um but the problem is
but this green guy there's only one
coordinate that leads you back to the
red set
whereas the unpredictability Dilemma
only allows you to flip like a typical
Gordon not the special one that brings
you back to the red guy
so in short I don't know how to make
this definition of mirrors at work and
certainly you know this idea of applying
the single bit flipping Lemma
um sort of runs into this this issue
so I'm going to adjust the definition of
a mirror set a little bit
so here's
yes the definition we will take
one bunch of yes inputs
well instead of looking at looking at
its immediate neighbors I just looked at
a larger Hamming ball so maybe I look at
the ball
of radius okay some lever cube root of n
parameters around X
okay if a Hamming ball that radius and I
ask
how many red points are there
and if I get many
I'm going to include this in my mirror
set
so you know I my mirror it just points
such that in my Hamming ball of certain
radius neighborhood I get many red
points okay
um so this is our
first attempt at the definition
okay
um so once you've defined the mirror set
now you just applied the same kind of
now we take the 3D step you know give me
a sub circuit that accepts a large
fraction of the mirror set
okay so the picture is something like
this
so I have a CNF
it accepts a large fraction of the
mirror set rejects all of the red set
okay so now the you know the What is the
the final step that I'm shooting by
wanna use this set
to construct a local limit in this set
that's my final contradiction
okay
so this is the goal
um okay this set I want to construct you
know this very specific limits in the
red set
okay so you know we sort of
um I'm not given two new challenges so
one was this you know construction of
the mirror set you know that's sort of
resolved another is
it's no longer enough for me to just
flip individual bits because uh you know
I don't know if there's any red points
directly next to me but I know there are
loads in a good distance away from me
so
for the
local limits I'm not going to flip the
individual bits but the whole blocks of
bits like jump a little bit further
okay so these are like the two
challenges in the proof
um
you know I've addressed the first
challenge of a candidate mirror set
um let me address the Second Challenge
so how do I
you know how do I protect local limits
that
I can obtain by flipping a whole block
well you know we just generalize this
limit to call blocks of bits so it's a
natural generalization
um the parameters change a little bit
so now you know you have three times the
cube root of n appearing that's by the
way optimal for this Lemma
um so yeah you have the same setup but
then instead of looking at an
unpredictable coordinate you look at a
whole block of coordinates
they choose this like cube root of n
many coordinates at random
and you would like to say this block is
completely unpredictable from other bits
so if you look at bits outside your
block
and you know condition with that
then well you can't predict much or
anything really about these bits so you
get
the full support so
um all possible bit patterns on this
block beam
okay so you know it's a kind of a
natural generalization of this Lemma
okay
so you know we sort of Hope to apply
this to the green set to get these like
bigger jumps
okay so but I still have to kind of land
inside the red set so here's the final
part of the puzzle
okay so again I had this um dense red
set I
constructed my mirror set of this green
points
and I made sure that um
well in the like vicinity of a green
point there are many Reds
and applying this Lemma from previous
slide I also know that
um for a well for typical green points
in the set like you know maybe the all
zero is one the Lemar applies so it
means that I can flip a large block I
mean but choose a typical block of this
size it will be a local limiter anything
any modification inside that block is
going to be a local limit
so how can I
now jump from the Green Point to a red
point so that one of these red points is
a local limit so here's
exactly the condition I would like to
have
um
so again I mean suppose the Lima block
unpredictably applies for the green
point so that sort of means that if
most choices of a block
I have my Global limit
um
I think I'm above
and it would be fantastic if I could you
know jump to a red point which means
that I have a red point
that I can jump to by only modifying the
points in B so sorry Jason notation a
little bit I'm thinking not of bit
vectors but indicators where the one
positions are so I think this is the
empty set
random look like this I get a local
limit but I would like to jump to one of
the red sets
so if I get
this probability this
a condition with high probability
then I I should be I'm sort of done
because I have two high probability
events like this and then um you know
this is you know satisfy the limit with
high probability
um
so how can we ensure I mean okay guys
like what what is this condition I've
written here Brian
does this look familiar or Shahar or
Anup Maybe
yeah so okay so this is just uh uh sort
of the definition of what a robust
sunflower is without a core
and so it's exactly what we need like
when we were working on this this
um
this popped up pretty naturally it's not
like we had this tool and we were trying
to hit this problem with it but it's
just a post-natural yeah
oh yeah so so I really need this
property and it doesn't hold for any
point it doesn't even hold for points
that I Define this way
but you know all this work on sunflowers
dilemma says that if you have such a
you know the point with you know a dense
many red points around it okay so maybe
this condition is not satisfied for X
itself but it's satisfied if I kind of
remove the core of a sunflower which in
our language just means moving the Green
Point a little bit
so that's okay so now I don't lie
anymore this is the final definition of
mirror set is that you kind of start
with this set and then you just like
move the point a little bit so it
becomes just the core of a sunflower so
then you can ensure this property this
is just a satisfying thing
[Music]
okay so that's pretty much it so the
proof just combines this
unpredictability and sunflower
um
I guess
so I mentioned that this top down proof
method is complete maybe I'll skip the
discussion sorry four of the sunflower
doesn't have to be small good point yeah
so with these parameters it turns out
it's always small so correspond to just
a slight movement of the Green Point
we got pretty of Joe's in the red set
different like you know you chose the
red set readily and then you chose the
green set and especially if the red set
could you have like chosen would it
still count as a top-down method if you
would like I mean yeah you can you could
be more clever in the first step I just
don't know how you would
you so so I'm sort of finally formalized
what I thought about
retained the green and red set each
point you didn't find a distribution on
one set and your what your return is a
large fraction of that so you kind of
moved your sub circuit that accepts a
large fraction of your original X
um and what's complete about this is
well the mirror set is sort of the
distribution here it follows some linear
programming majority there's always
a choice of a distribution okay to lower
about hold this if you want
you know construct a set of yes input is
a union a few
sets exactly lower down there's always a
distribution kind of witnesses that
hardness uh it's just very you know this
is non-constructive so what we've only
done like when you instantiate this you
have to
effective explicit description of the
distribution that's sort of what it
means to keep a top-down method in my
mind
okay but I did wrap up
um
so the obvious distribution there
it depends on the classes at one level
below
so distribution is not supposed to
depend on the lower level you're not
allowed to look lower down you're only
allowed to say you know you have these
sets you define the distribution and
then adversarially I return you know any
circuit that accepts a long fraction of
that that's sort of the gaming yeah
maybe this is not in the literature
anyway but this is how I think about it
but this is what counts for a top-down
method that's why it's called pass down
yeah
it's like approximate right it has like
okay so yeah you do lose some factors
polynomial factors
okay thank you
um black four yeah I mean so we got this
result uh earlier this year and then
we'll try to extend it to higher depths
but
we're just stumped I we don't know some
sort of sunflower type
sort of and I don't know if this would
help
or something like this
you think it's like a lot of work yeah
so I don't know of any kind of I didn't
even yeah so I lack the method I don't
know that kind of the definition of
mirror sets and okay so just everything
just doesn't work because before just a
small number
support
yeah I don't know what would be the
unpredictable is level one level higher
I don't know if there is one
maybe an easier the question is
would be easier than themselves
yeah I think it's an incomparable
question but uh it could be
yeah so yeah I think this is pretty
tough I mean it's one of my sort of
favorite
problems too it's
um so yeah and this person your
motivation for me to do this
is there some
um well first
um maybe I remember this incorrectly but
if I remember if you put more than two
to the square root n for that three uh
then you start to get like these near
Long depth or bonds and Valiants yeah so
is there some barrier for these sickness
across through the squared end or is is
that just a
well I mean not for the top down because
it's complete but uh
um yeah it's true the best we have are
the balance you should see for parity so
it's hard to say like what is the thing
we're hitting up against
where is the function right like you
need a harder function
as well yeah
oh yeah I mean you uh yeah there's a
function too
so you don't see anything yeah
[Music]
oh so but it's like block on
predictability whether we just said you
get full support but you know do you get
maybe close to uniform on that uh block
we didn't work it out but I presume you
do
all right hey now any questions thank
you again